مايكل مينر هو أستاذ مساعد
في علم الأوبئة في مدرسة هارفارد تي
إتش تشان للصحة العامة ،
ومن الجيد أن أراك طبيب آخر مرة
تحدثنا فيها في كانون الأول (ديسمبر) ،
لقد قدمت حجة قوية للاختبار المنزلي الرخيص
حتى يعرف الناس ما
إذا كانوا معديين قبل
مغادرتهم  المنزل الذي تغير
منذ ذلك الحين من حيث التوافر أو
الخطط لإيصالها إلى الناس
بشكل جيد ، وأكبر شيء
تغير بالطبع هو أن لدينا
إدارة جديدة في الولايات
المتحدة وقد جعل الرئيس بايدن من أولوياتنا
تكثيف الجهود حقًا  الاختبار السريع
كجزء من الاستجابة الشاملة
لفيروس كورونا الذي كان يجمعه
جنبًا إلى جنب مع إدارته ،
لذا أعتقد أننا بدأنا الآن في
رؤية
أه بعض الأدلة على أنهم يحملون من
خلال أنهم بدأوا في القيام
باستثمارات متزايدة في  بعض
شركات الاختبار السريع
أه للمساعدة في توسيع نطاقها
ونأمل أن يتم عرض هذه الاختبارات على
الجمهور الأمريكي ،
نعم إنهم ينظرون إلى أه نصف
دزينة  أعتقد أن المرشحين للاختبار السريع ولكن
المرشح الذي سيدفعونه
هو من
النول وأنا أعلم أن هذا هو السعر الذي
يبحثون عنه عن كثب
وهو
ثلاثون دولارًا وهو الاختبار
الذي دفعت من أجله  هذه الاختبارات
التي أعتقد أن البنسات
هي أنه من الواقعي أن يكون لدينا ثلاثون
اختبارًا بالدولار سيستخدمها الناس أكثر
مما تعرف مرة واحدة في القمر الأزرق
الآن اختبار illume هو آه اختبار جيد
ولكنه سيكون حقًا  أكثر من
اختبار لمرة واحدة للأشخاص ،
لن يكون هذا
النوع المتكرر من الاختبار الذي كنت أدعو إليه ،
فالاختبارات المتكررة هي في الحقيقة
مجرد اختبارات بسيطة لشرائط الورق تشبه إلى حد كبير
اختبار الحمل ولكن لا توجد إلكترونيات ولا
بطاريات
ولا بلوتوث  مجرد اختبار بسيط للغاية
يمكن للأشخاص استخدامه
مرتين أو ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع في منازلهم ،
وهو نوع من الاختبارات السريعة والمتكررة
والتي نحتاجها حقًا للمساعدة في
السيطرة على مرض كوفيد
في الولايات المتحدة وعادل
وعادل  س الحقيقي  بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين لا
يعرفون مزايا الأشخاص الذين لديهم
هذه
الأشياء في خزانة الحمام الخاصة بهم ، يقومون بذلك ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع ، لذا فإن أفضل شيء في إجراء
الاختبارات المتكررة هو أنه يمكنك معرفة
أنك معدي
قبل أن تخرج فعليًا وتصيب
يجب استخدام هذه الاختبارات على الأشخاص الآخرين
بحيث إذا كنت تستخدمها
مرتين أو ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع ، فإنها تستغرق
حوالي 30 ثانية لاستخدامها فعليًا
ثم حوالي 15 دقيقة للانتظار حتى تظهر
النتيجة وهذا يكفي لتنظيف
تستخدم اختبار kova للأسنان
، وإذا كانت سلبية ، فاستمر في
يومك تمامًا كما كنت ستحصل عليه ،
ولكن إذا كان ذلك إيجابيًا ،
فستبقى في المنزل لعدة أيام
ولا تذهب إلى العمل لا تذهب إلى العمل.  لن تذهب إلى
المدرسة ، فأنت لا تذهب لرؤية عائلتك
لتناول عشاء ليلة الجمعة ،
فأنت مخول لاتخاذ
خيارات أه من شأنها أن تساعدك على منع
نفسك من نشر الفيروس
لأشخاص آخرين
وإذا كنت لا تختبر
كثيرًا من
أجل  فيروس مثل ج  oronavirus ،
فمن المرجح أن تفوتك
نافذة الإرسال إذا كنت
تختبر مرة كل أسبوعين باستخدام اختبار
pcr ، فمن غير المحتمل أن
تلتقط نفسك بالفعل
قبل أن تذهب وتنقل إلى
أشخاص آخرين إذا استغرق اختبار pcr أسبوعين أو
ثلاثة أيام للعودة
ومن ثم من غير المحتمل أن تلاحق
نفسك
قبل أن تستمر في إصابة
أشخاص آخرين ، وبالتالي فإن هذه الأنواع من الاختبارات هذه الأنواع
الرخيصة حقًا
من الاختبارات الورقية التي يمكن أن تكون
مستضدًا ، ويمكن أيضًا أن تكون اختبارات rna هذه هي
من النوع الذي نرغب فيه أننا بحاجة إلى رؤية
الخروج إلى منازل الناس
حتى يتمكنوا من فعل ذلك بشكل متكرر بما يكفي
لإيقاف انتقالهم بأنفسهم